du fühlst dich einfach in deinem eigenen
körper gefangen du kannst dich nicht
konzentrieren
du kannst nicht essen das ist alles sehr
sehr schwer das auch zu erklären wie es
in einem vorgeht
[Musik]
ich habe mich dann immer mehr
zurückgezogen weil es mir schlecht da
ging und bei mustern liegt das ist das
was ich tun sollte aber es war auch das
was ich dagegen erforderlich war
[Musik]
zurück auf dem fußball-platz endlich
mathias münch trainierte den fsv
bretzenheim eine dunkle zeit liegt
hinter ihm
meine diagnosen sind schwere
depressionen panikattacken angststörung
schlafstörung burnout es fing alles an
mit der pandemie auch arbeitstechnisch
gesehen
man ist in kurzarbeit gekommen dann war
alles so ungeregelt man musste nicht wo
vorne und hinten ist dann hab ich bei
dem arbeitgeber aufgehört zu arbeiten
und dann wurde gab es noch im nachhinein
stress und damit wohl das immer
schlimmer matthias ist gelernter
fahrzeuglackierer die berufliche
unsicherheit belastet ihn schwer
zugleich bricht weg was ihm sonst gut
tut da ist eigentlich ein sehr
sportlicher mensch bin auch fast jeden
tag auf dem sportplatz war da war man
dann plötzlich überall eingeschränkt man
hat seine freundin nicht mehr getroffen
man konnte kein fußball mehr spielen
das hat mir dann auch sehr gefehlt
die kontakt armut setzt auch sarah
spieker aus neuenrade schwer zu die
ingenieurin muss ins home office als die
pandemie beginnt im jahr zuvor war sie
an einer depression erkrankt und gerade
dabei ein neues gleichgewicht zu finden
dann mit pluto angefangen also als
verein sport in der gruppe habe auch
kontakte zu freunden wieder intensiviert
und mich nicht nur so wie vorher so auf
die arbeit fokussiert und habe auch
versucht ein bisschen mein
perfektionismus und leistungsanspruch
abgelegen und eben in der freizeit auch
dinge zu tun auf die ich irgendwie lust
habe die mir freude machen und da auch
erst mal wieder so ein gefühl zu
bekommen so was macht mir freude und
dann habe ich mit klettern angefangen
ihr habt da mit yoga auf einer kuppe
angefangen und dann kam die pandemie und
dann sind diese ganzen bereiche die ich
mir so ausgesucht habe dem ich ja auch
dann stabilisieren
von einfach auf den anderen war es ja
ungefähr vor einem jahr gefühl
weggefallen
zunächst kommt sarah noch klar im ersten
shut down ist sie viel draußen es ist
wie ein kleines abenteuer
doch als es in den herbst geht schlägt
ihre stimmung generell ist angstgefühl
auch bei vielen gesellschaft gewesen
dass irgendjemand vor dem virus auch
sorgen jetzt dann auch ja richtig schwer
gefallen überhaupt noch im freude zu
empfinden oder mich auch so von diesen
sorgen irgendwie loszulösen ich habe
gemerkt ich konnte mich nicht mehr
konzentrieren
ich habe ganz schlecht geschlafen
schnell irgendwie angefangen zu weinen
auch kaum was zugetraut sind ausgelöst
aber ich kann gar nicht arbeiten
ich hoffe dass alles nicht
auch meine familie wäre besser dran wenn
ich nicht mehr da bin
düstere gedanken die quälen typisch für
eine depression matthias wird immer
unruhiger dabei sollte 2020 ein
glückliches jahr für ihn werden
der 33 jährige heiratet und wird zum
zweiten mal vater
es sind viele veränderungen auf einmal
er fühlt sich überfordert
vielen hat es prima gemacht vor allem
mit schlafstörungen und übelkeit
erbrechen
ich hatte auch absolut keinen appetit
mehr
oft hat man so einfach das gefühl gehabt
man hat so einen druck im kopf
kopfschmerzen man wäre verspannt man
kann eigentlich gar nicht mehr zur ruhe
man muss nicht ob man sich hinlegen soll
oder ob man sich bewegen soll
nach außen spielt er den staaten während
in ihm wie ein innerer schatten die
depression alles verdunkelt ihn gefangen
hält
man hat so eine innere leere gehabt man
wusste nicht mehr was man am besten
machen soll
man hat sich sehr zurückgezogen auch aus
dem freundeskreis und dann habe ich
nachts geträumt dass ich mit
vorzugsweise und da wusste ich jetzt
geht es nicht mehr um ihn daraufhin zum
arzt sieben wochen kommt matthias
stationär in die fachklinik im
rheinhessischen alzey
hier berichten viele depressiv erkrankte
dass sie leiden in der pandemie und ihre
krankheit sich verschlechtert gesunde
leute sagen würden das glas ist halb
voll oder halb leer da sagen die
depressiven patienten das glas ist
eigentlich leer
es ist da ist gar nichts mehr drin im
glas heißt also eine deutlich negativere
sicht auf die welt ist ohnehin in der
depression da und jetzt sind sie umgeben
letzten endes von negativen nachrichten
das heißt ich hab sozialen rückzug auf
der einen seite eine verstärkung der
negativen position auf der anderen seite
und beides feuert letzten endes die
depression weiter an
eine studie der stiftung deutsche
depressionshilfe zeigt in den letzten
sechs monaten haben depressionen sich
massiv verschlechtert
44 prozent der depressiv erkrankten
berichten von negativen folgen diese
sind bei 16 prozent stärkere symptomatik
bei weiteren 16 prozent ein rückfall und
8 prozent der menschen mit depression
haben gar suizidgedanken oder suizidale
impulse bei sarah bricht die krankheit
von neuem aus die 36-jährige durchlebt
schwere wochen ist krankgeschrieben
grübelt viel halt findet sie in einem
gut strukturierten tagesablauf mir hilft
nicht schreibt meine disziplin und eine
große stütze war mir dann auch meine
mutter die mich dann als ich so gar
keine motivation hat und hier alles
irgendwie zu viel war einfach mich so
geschnappt hat und die sache jetzt
spazieren
wir fahren irgendwohin laufen bisschen
sehr gut mit hilfe ihrer
psychotherapeutin lernt sarah ihre
gedanken neu zu lenken
die therapie motiviert sie hier bekommt
sie viele anregungen die ihr helfen
psychisch stabiler zu werden ihren
alltag ihre zukunft aktiv zu gestalten
diagnose depression matthias war
zunächst erschrocken nun geht er
offensiv damit um auf facebook ermutigt
der andere sich ebenfalls hilfe zu holen
teilt was er aus seiner krankheit lernt
also die depression bei mir
hauptsächlich kam über stress und druck
ich war auch so ein perfektionist bei
mir muss nicht alles 100 prozent sein
sondern 150
vorher war ich ein mensch der vieles
machen wollte auch viele menschen
beeindrucken wollte oder ist auch
versucht hat allen recht zu machen
mittlerweile bin ich an dem punkt
angekommen wo ich sage man kann es nicht
allen recht machen in erster linie
sollte man immer auf sich achten wie es
einem persönlich geht bevor man sich
gedanken um andere macht der
fußballverein liegt dem unverändert am
herzen
die mannschaft steht hinter ihm und
manche finden den neuen trainer sogar
besser als den alten war sehr wichtig
immer geschäft zu sein war ich mal und
er wollte seine vision auf jeden fall
durchsetzen auch beim fußball gerade und
nach der geschichte ist auch sehr
verständnisvoll geworden auch noch jung
ist das wichtig ist dass ihr euch selber
keinen stress macht da ist ein bisschen
netter gewohnten ruhiger geworden er ist
nicht mal so lässt sich nicht so schnell
unter druck setzen und es ist ziemlich
nett und er schreibt nicht mehr so viel
auf dem platz
matthias ist weiter in therapie und
sieht sich auf einem guten weg es liegt
in meiner hand weil die medikamente
alleine machen das nicht sie
unterstützen nur ich muss jetzt schauen
wo sind meine grenzen bis wohin kann ich
gehen was macht nicht anders allein
liegt es nur an mir
inzwischen arbeitet er wieder in einer
anderen branche als früher mit weniger
stress es geht voran in ein besseres
leben
auch sarah hat einen neuen job sie wird
bald mittelständische unternehmen bei
der digitalisierung beraten
eine anspruchsvolle aufgabe auf die sie
sich freut
begleitet von ihrer langzeittherapie
sieht sie nun optimistisch in die
zukunft
ich weiß jetzt einfach dass das leben
immer positive und schöne seiten hat und
auch immer wieder herausforderungen und
schwierige zeiten und dann wenn sie mir
dann schlecht da gehen sollte hoffe ich
jetzt dass ich dann auch in der phase
dann sagen kann okay das ist jetzt im
moment und es geht auch um den nächsten
tagen wochen monaten wieder besser gehen
[Musik]